Hey, what's going on? This
fucking damn thing. I, you know,
I ordered the stupid part. I swear
to God. I'm picking it up today.
God dammit. Let me hold it on to it
like a terrorist for the last time. Hey,
what's going on? It's Bellbird is
time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday
morning podcast. Dan. Ah,
just checking in on you.
How the fuck was your God damn Christmas.
Why is this wire all fucked up?
God fucking dammit.
I swear to Christ. I said this was the
last fucking time I was doing this.
Did Not.
It was not what I said.
Okay.
You know,
it's really fucking amazing
is the abilities for wires
to just get off fucking
hard. If you look at it, it's
like, how did that happen?
How the fuck did this whole fucking
thing go down like this? The headphones.
The fucking headphones.
All right. Hang in there.
For Fuck's sakes. Yeah.
You feel better because
I'm losing my shit.
Does that make you feel better about your
fucking cubicle dwell and fucking lie?
Well,
I hope it does.
I hope it does because I'm all about
the positive vibes in the two to the one
MSI, Tory 19. Um,
how are you?
Did you have,
hey,
merry little Christmas.
Did you get through it without arguing?
I forgot to give you guys a pep top.
Don't take the fucking bait.
All right?
If one of you have siblings is a Trump
supporter or they're a fucking liberal
Larry or their there
centrist centrus Susan
never picked the side.
Jesus Christ.
Only fucking person
I know could be a serial
killer and be like, wow,
I guess I can understand
why you need to feed.
Oh yeah. Really talked to me. When
you end up in a trunk, Susan. Um,
there's no reason to do that. There's
no reason to do it because the gear,
you're not going to get what you want,
which is the satisfaction
of the other person going,
oh my God,
I never realized how right you are.
It wasn't until you called me a closed
minded fuck head that I just stopped and
paused and was like,
wait a minute.
Okay.
Am I close my eyes and my
cousin, I, you're a fucking,
you're a fucking believe what Cath
candidate comic. Cause my fac hair.
Yeah. And Christmas, it's like, Hello
Colin. You stocking much. You
know what? I fucking can't stand.
I can't stand when new speak comes out.
Okay.
I get it. Back in the day, you know when
we were cave men walking around like, oh,
ah,
doing that shit. You know, you had
to come up with some fucking words
so you wouldn't like be asking for,
you know,
some water but yet sound like you were
going off.
Ha ha ha.
Ah, that's the noises I make. Um, it's
why I do at my garage. I don't want to
while there anybody,
no.
And I also understand it if
something new comes along.
Yeah.
You know?
Like an iPod.
What were you supposed to call it?
Okay.
A little stereo. I don't fucking
know. Right. I understand those words.
I just hate when new fucking words come
around and then everybody just starts
fucking saying them.
It drives me up the fucking wall.
Especially like on Twitter
when there's the new uh,
or Instagram.
Okay.
And, and they just come when they
go, remember the for a while,
like when you posted something,
someone will just go this,
you know?
Yeah.
And then with what? Some other,
that's stupid shit out there.
I can't fucking stand. Just drives
me up. It's so fucking under rich.
I just had somebody give me shit saying
something I tweeted wasn't funny and
they used the Gif. It's,
and I brought the guy back.
At least I'm fucking right in my
own jokes. You're fucking hack.
Someone had to like fucking think of a
funny response to my unfunny joke for you
with a little video on it.
And now you feel like you're clever.
I just drives me. What the fuck, you know?
Okay.
I just got back into working out.
Right.
Fucking if I hear one more fucking young,
cause I got those, those TRX bands.
Yeah.
All right. If I hear one more dose,
tell me that I'm engaging my core.
He made working my abs.
You fake Tan cunt.
Okay.
And what's great about these is
you're always a little off balance.
You're always engaging your core,
you know, board a plane anymore.
You expedite the boarding process.
Step back like you got to do great.
You're fucking waitress.
Um,
do you guys get that? Put your jackets
to the overhead required me to,
we can expedite the boarding.
Bragg says,
do you want to sound like you
have a fucking law degree?
You're on here for one fucking
reason only and that's cheap airfare.
Stop acting like it was a dream.
I like to travel.
Okay.
I like to wear a uniform.
Yeah.
I like to expedite the boarding
process while engaging my core.
This.
Okay.
Hashtag shaking my head
yes.
You fucking Twitter of question.
How Times have you hashtag shaking my
head and you actually were shaking your
head.
Okay.
I'm trying to think.
Last time I fucking shook my head
and I should probably do it a lot.
It's fun when I try to keep my,
my fucking cool.
I'm driving is fucking guy. Oh my God.
These fucking assholes out here on,
on the highways. The way they pass you on
the right hand side, it's unbelievable.
You can get into the left lane doing
like 40 miles an hour. You, you,
you want to get off the highway,
you got to be doing like 120 and you
watch them pass, you can do an 80,
and you look in their lane and there's
a guy a quarter mile away and they're
going to have to stop
on the fucking brakes.
I think it's just psychologically
psychological outta here that, that,
that there's so much traffic that you
just think to yourself like, you know,
anytime there's an open space, you're
like, ah, you just fucking Florida.
Well maybe I'm just that dose shoe has
like the baby on board sign in his head.
I have no idea. Um, but speaking of cars,
my latest obsession,
but I was going to buy a car right now.
All right? If I was a single
man, if I didn't have a child,
if I had a full head of
hair to flow in the breeze,
I would get the Porsche Targa
the fast one. All right.
In lava orange, she
just liked my pubes. Um,
because I am a child of the 70s,
and she remember that Shit
in Boogie nights when Philip
Seymour Hoffman rest his
soul, he's talking to mark
Wahlberg's character. Any,
any says how the corvette
is in a competition? Orange.
That was my favorite fucking detail.
Yeah.
Uh,
seventies detail competition orange.
Oh, he didn't wait. He didn't have
one. He had the, he had a, uh, oh no.
Mark Wahlberg's character got the
corvette and competition orange and then
Philip Seymour Hoffman showed up with
like a Datsun two 40 z or something.
Still a decent car. Right. Um,
but it's, it's no corvette.
Um, anyways, I got to see
what that looks like is,
I hope it's not a red orange. I'd
want an orange, orange. You know,
there's a lot of things right
now it's just like, I don't know,
everybody's got to start fucking
with the colors, but that thing,
and it's got the automatic
fucking a rooftop.
It was actually Porsche enthusiasts who
are engaging their core when they press
the fucking send button
on the youtube comment.
We're complaining actually complaining.
The old one you did.
You had to,
you had to do it by hand and then fold
up the cloth top and then put it in the
bonnet is, they say overseas,
put it under the fucking hood.
Now this one,
you just push a button.
Okay.
The backend lifts up a little bit and then
the top fucking goes down like the ED.
It's, it's, it's a fucking work of art and
there's all these cuts, right? And like,
ah, leave it to the Germans
to take something really
simple and make it a fucking
what?
Make it fucking perfect.
Yeah.
Someone's like going, I would be
concerned if I, there were so many could,
but behind me, I mean, that comes a
good two feet up behind the car. Well,
they fucking pull up the tires,
do one rotation and then push your button.
I'm amazed that when they designed this,
are you amazed
the fuck are you ever designed?
Oh, why am I in such a mood?
You know what? I just, I had a bad night's
sleep. I had this dream that I was,
I was playing the Wilma theater in Boston,
Massachusetts. One of my favorite
promoters out there, Bill Bloom and Reich,
he was in my dream and he
was talking the way right.
Talks to him. Right Bro? I saw that
article I wrote about your word. You,
you're really shared some
mean things about mers.
I was like, are we talking about, I
would never say mean things about you.
I love you.
No,
just kind of car came off a little mean.
So I felt like an asshole.
Like however I was joking about him,
somebody it came off
his fucking main site,
apologized to him and
then I go out on stage.
Okay.
This was a stress dream cause I hadn't
been on stage in like five fucking days.
Uh,
and I got this European tour coming up.
So I just booked myself with the
comedy store starting last night,
right through Sunday. Just going
to do as much stage time as I can.
And I had a great set last night.
I Dunno. It's just, I think, uh,
you know,
I just know I got a fucking,
I needed to do all these nights and
then I'll then I'll be fine when I go to
Europe,
but whatever.
MMM.
So I go out on stage in my dream on the
Wilbur theater and if for some reason
it's like six stories in the air,
six stories up,
and there's people way down
below who clearly can't see me.
And I feel like I have to
walk to the edge of the stage,
but I don't want to fall down and I'm
making fun of it and nobody's laughing.
I'm just bombing. And for some
reason I'm on eye level, um,
with the six story balcony level and
they're just staring at me and I'm not
doing well.
Yeah.
And then halfway through my set and
there's all these obstructions to like,
I'm walking and all of a sudden I'm
like behind some giant pole and nobody's
laughing. And I'm like, oh my
God, what the fuck am I doing?
And at one point I was laying down on
the stage crawling towards the edge
because it was also really dark.
And I couldn't see how deep it went down.
I dropped the Mike down there,
somebody turned on a record player and I
shut it off. And it was just like, hey,
slowed down. Wasn't that song? I
don't know why I just picked that.
Maybe cause I'm a dancing monkey on stage.
I have no fucking idea.
And then halfway through it,
one of the few comics that I don't like
in this business came fucking walking
out like the selfish cunt that he or she
is and picked up like a little square
fridge that you'd have the when you
lived in like a studio apartment.
Okay.
And I was like, really? And the
person was like, yeah, really?
And they just fucking took and started
walking out. And I said the person's name,
I said from the bottom of my heart,
I fucking hate you.
And then I quickly shut up,
cause I knew everybody in the crowd was
going to film it. Um, and what's funny is,
is I don't really hate this person in
real life. I just fucking avoid him.
You know?
That's what a great thing about getting
older is you stop hating people.
You just sort of like, you avoid them.
Even if you're sitting next to him,
you just mentally avoid them. He
just like, okay, I know who you are,
I know how you act and
this is what I expect,
so I'm not going to get upset. I'm just
fucking knocked gauging it, you know?
And uh,
okay.
And then somewhere along the line they
turned the lights on and I realized that
I wasn't six stories in the air.
Okay.
That the stage was still the
same height it usually was.
And then all of a sudden the
microphone worked and I could start,
okay.
You know, doing my job and
I started killing again. So
maybe the dream was, Bill,
you have an irrational fear about taking
four or five days off from standup.
I will tell you last night I fucking,
uh,
I went on stage and I got this new Bush,
Michelle Obama bit that was bombing,
you know, cause she's so fucking
precious. You know what I mean? I don't,
I don't know why,
out of all the first ladies,
every first lady has always been made fun
of her for some fucking reason is like
off limits. So you know, as a
comedian something is off limits,
you know, you kind of have to steer
the ship towards it at one point just,
just for the fun of it.
Right.
Okay.
So last night was the first night,
uh,
I started to get that started
to get it to work and um,
I tried a another bit,
you know, about this,
this gay kid,
you know,
parents didn't know she was gay and the
parents were like fucking people that
think he can pray away being gay.
Um,
what can you pray away? Oh, I went to
church by the way. I got there late,
you know, I felt bad. I got there,
register fucking guy was starting
his homily and I was like, ah, fuck.
And then part of me was psyched because
I didn't have to sit through the first
two readings.
MMM.
And uh, they really switched up the
words a lot. The shit that you say,
they switched it up a lot. I was like,
is this like some west coast thing?
My mother in law like Nah, they
kind of changed it up. You know,
he used to be peace,
be with you and also with they like
added a bunch of words like peace be with
you.
And I uh,
I concur that also and would
wish that upon use to sir.
Slash Ma'am you've got to say all that
before you should fucking shake hands
with somebody. Um, I dunno,
I haven't been to church in a while.
I literally thought my suit was going
to catch on fire when I walked in there.
That's when you know you're
a piece of shit. You know,
you haven't been there in awhile.
You just walk in and you're just thinking
of all this shit God would be saying
to you if he really exists and you just
walking in and going, I know, I know.
You know. And then after a while he gets
stubborn and be like, well, you don't do,
you know, technically you made me
so whatever my fucking flaws are,
I know you have this convenient excuse
of the devil. You know what I mean?
I mean, what the fuck? Hey, you know,
I made you perfect, but you
listened to the devil. Well,
did you make the devil toe?
Okay?
Isn't all of this you're
fucking grand scheme,
right?
I actually, when I look at God that
way, right? If he exist, you know,
and it is a he. Okay. Because
at the end of the day, you know,
when you really look at the world,
most of the great things that
were created were done by men.
And I don't know why I have to shy
away from that and this progressive,
but you know,
ladies,
why don't you put your fucking brains
where your mouth though and fucking start
inventing some shit.
And I know you're going to come
at me with this fucking list that,
that is impressive to you.
But I,
what I also want you to Google my
feminist little friends is what have men
invented? And you watch that fucking
there. It's fucking Dan Marino,
1984 48 touchdowns,
5,800 fucking yards when you could still
beat the shit out of a wide receiver
and a quarterback. Um, having
said that, I uh, I respect,
love it and I feel you're very brave at
a time you put out your lab coat ad set
out to make a new widget.
Okay.
And it's so much harder for
a woman to put on a lab coat.
I'm just trying to make
sure I have it all down. Um,
just someday I would like to host an award
show and I have to make sure that I'm
the fucking Zombie that
they're looking for. MMM,
I'll do,
I'll come out and do a monologue just
talking about how dumb men are and how we
can't even figure out how to dress
ourselves without women. You know,
all of that shit and they'll
just fucking eat it up.
This is another thing I fucking hate.
You know what I hate?
I hate when a co a running back gets
like fucking 40 caries and he has like 47
yards and then he finally breaks one
for about 15 and then he gets up and he
does that. I'm eating a bowl of
oatmeal thing. It's like, buddy,
we've been feeding you the
fucking ball all God damn game.
Once you go look at your
fucking yardage average,
you're 2.7 yards per carry cunt.
Um,
okay.
Hey Bill, how about something
positive? All right.
I got something positive for you.
I watched this fucking Celtics
first of Philadelphia, 76, six,
you know, fucking blew me away in that
game. Was that Joelle, Joelle and beep.
So you say his name. I'm not looking
it up because I can't spell it. Um,
evidently that guy played a soccer
or football as they call it over the,
over the fucking sees there.
Um,
yeah.
Until late in his life.
I gotta tell you something.
That guy is like a ridiculous factor when
he's on the court and I know he's one
of the guys in the league, but
I don't, I don't think, uh,
yeah,
I don't think he's getting
the respect he deserves.
That fucking guy is a problem.
Okay.
On both ends of the court blocking shots,
getting rebound scoring points.
Fucking asis moves great for a big man.
Um,
okay.
I am praying to the basketball gods.
Look at me,
I'm going to church and I'm fucking
all about every God out there now.
Okay.
Um, I can't, you feel the, the joy
that's coming back into my life, my life.
It's like the end of the
Grinch, isn't it? Um,
I am praying to the basketball
gods that the, the, uh,
that the Celtics in [inaudible] 76
is a gonna fucking play again. Um,
I don't even care if we lose. That's
how much I enjoy that playoff series.
Some back in the day when I used
to watch Andrew Tony and Dr Jay,
Bobby Jones, Billy Cunningham, all
his mother fuckers coming at town,
Daryl Dawkins the first time
through and then it was Moses.
MMM.
Anyways, the fuck was I just going
to talk about, oh, I remember. Oh,
so I'm reading this book on Bob Cousy and
uh, Bill Russell called the last pass.
Does that really count as reading
by the way, to read about sports?
I don't think it does. It's like a long
sports page as far as I'm concerned. Um,
okay.
I don't know if I brought this up already.
I forget,
but like for the longest time I thought,
okay.
That the first
NBA basketball player with the
sneaker deal was Michael Jordan.
Now he might've had wait
his name on the sneaker,
but then I found out that
those red and white converse,
we're called the doctor J's,
but the,
I don't remember them having his
name on it initially. So then,
um,
I'm reading this book.
Okay.
And I find out that Bob Cousy and
likes 1962 or 63 had his own sneaker.
He signed a deal with pf flyers and
it looks like a bootleg chuck Taylor.
And I found a pair on,
on fucking Ebay for 155 bucks.
I didn't buy him,
but cause I'm not a
sneaker head. Yo. Uh, Yo,
you see the dude Jordan 48, um,
what are they up to by the way?
What are they up to?
It is amazing that 30 years has gone by.
He must have a new sneaker every year.
I would say they're on the Jordan 32.
So let's look this, well, let's
finish this story. So Bob Cousy,
that's the one that I want, you know,
I'm kind of fascinated by that whole
mmm.
A sneaker culture as far as like,
okay,
you know, all the different, like do you
get the Sundale three fours or whatever,
you know,
Jordan's 2019 let's see
what they got coming up.
What do they got in the, in the,
in, in the fucking sneaker barrel.
Air Jordan.
One retro sample.
Okay.
Oh, it was a sample. So that's not
exactly what they came out with.
And they want $4,000 for those. Are
you fucking kidding me? What do you do?
How do,
what do you sneak hedge?
So you put them on the wall so you feel
like you're always in a footlocker. Uh,
Air Jordan release 2018 all right,
let's see. What are they up to here?
Air Jordan.
okay.
How the fuck are they? Only on the
12th. All right. Air Jordan nine
dude verse, he sent me a text
the other day was fucking
hilarious. He's like, dude,
Jordan,
three MOCHA fucking over.
And it was the Jordan threes with
this mocha color cement thing
and I fucking died laughing.
I mean, he's, he's like,
he's like that fucking chick
day with the thin head.
Sarah Jessica Parker on sex in the city.
So rather than talking about fucking
high heels, he's talking about sneakers.
MMM.
Anyway,
so Bob Cousy,
he had a pair of pf flyers and you know
with a little circle is on the chuck
Taylor was his face and it said Bob Cousy
on it and they were black and they had
a little green trim on them.
So that's as far back for all
you fucking sneaker heads there.
I know Kareem Abdul Jabbar, he had
his own, did he have his own sneaker?
Ucla low top Adita I dunno,
but w who was like the first guy actually
he had like his name on it though
because I think maybe the technically,
okay.
The doctor Jay Converse just said,
um,
we're just nicknamed the doctor J's,
but they said converse on. He says,
let me look that up,
Doctor Jay. Conversely,
this is why I like talking shit about
things cause then I ended up getting into
it like fucking the pro,
the premier league.
MMM.
All right, let's see here.
Yeah, those are the classic
classic converse all stars. I
don't see his name on it. Oh.
And then eventually they did.
But the original one,
one of the cleanest fucking
shoes ever that for some reason
I think the newer ones said when I was
a kid, they didn't say dr j on him.
And now I'm looking at a really
old pair and those ones say dr j.
So I think after a while they said doctor
Jay and those things look like they
came up before the year Jordan. But as
far as I can tell the Bob fucking cozy.
Okay.
The koozie ones do.
There was somebody fucking way back to
God coochie ones with a pork pie hat
fucking over Shea. Um, all right.
Let me look at some stuff here.
Uh,
I missed the last two Liverpool Games.
I get all wrapped up in the holidays
and I cannot fucking believe this.
I don't know anything about
the Wolverhampton Wanderers,
but somehow we lost to them.
Okay.
We beat new castle United four to nothing,
but the fucking wolves means guys
don't even look like they, they there.
There's nothing premiere about their,
their uniform, their fucking name
or anything.
What happened?
Yeah.
Mohammed Silo and virtual van Dutch
struck to claim, oh no, they won.
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
And that doesn't make any fucking sense.
That doesn't make any fucking sense.
Cause we beat Manchester United three
to one and it says three to one.
Yeah.
And then it says Fuckin zero two.
So I guess they do that all
cause that was an away game.
Yeah.
Ah, your cheeky cons. All right. I learned
something else. That's how they do it.
Okay.
So they got arsenal one nil
arsenal coming up. The only one,
only Premier Li game, uh, I've ever
been to. I told you they played Everton.
It's fucking hilarious.
And they went up one to nothing and
they started singing one Neal arsenal in
halfway through the fucking
song ever written scored.
And this little blue
puff of smoke came up.
Yeah.
The 40 Everton fans,
we're going fucking nuts.
And all the arsenal people had to shut
the fuck up. Uh, I love when that happens.
Yeah.
I was watching a ranger game earlier
this year and fucking as always,
Henrik Lundqvist was playing unbelievable
and the whole garden is going and rig
lug was Henrik Lundqvist or whatever.
And as the chance that the
other team fucking scored.
Uh Huh.
It's what you get. All right. Let's
look at some Google news here.
We'll start with the greatest country in
America, the United States of America.
All right? After Trump visits, Iraq,
lawmakers demand US withdrawal.
Finally,
let's get the fuck outta their way.
We're going bankrupt.
Iraqi lawmakers demand withdraw Baghdad,
Iraqi lawmakers.
This is the greatest thing that could
fucking happen to us if we combine it with
solar power.
Yeah.
In electric cars.
All right?
You gotta hit them where it hurts.
Just like the feminists do.
The feminists go after the money.
They go after the advertisers.
This is what the fuck you got to
do in the Middle East. All right.
Truly, the great thing though, as if we
pull out, I believe they'll just go back.
Unfortunately, because I don't have
a problem with Middle Eastern people.
I just have a problem with cunts. Okay.
And cuts. They're everywhere. Right.
Um, as long as you're not a client,
I don't have a problem with you.
So I think that they'll go back
to trying to fucking, you know,
deal with each other. Hopefully
not in a violent way, but you know,
it's going to be,
but I always looked at it like the way
when Russia withdrew from fucking Europe,
everybody was like, okay, where were we?
And they just picked up what their
fights again. It's really se I, I,
for the life of me,
I'll never understand how war is legal.
MMM.
You know,
we're sitting here like working on gender
neutral bathrooms while war is still
legal. I mean it's just fucking nuts. You
know what it is. I think it's cause they,
they keep updating the
war, the, uh, the weapons.
So it seems modern,
you know,
but if you still went out there like the
Braveheart days, and there was, you know,
two people standing on opposing hills
and then they just ran down the hill
yelling,
oh,
just fucking met in the valley. And
they had those sticks with the fucking,
uh, the, the, the, the fucking cannon
ball with the spikes coming out of it.
You know,
basically you're dressing a raider fan,
except you can actually hurt somebody.
You don't have the rubber points.
You wouldn't want to put somebody's eye
out when you're intimidating somebody.
Raider fans. Um, all right. So politicians
from both blocks of Iraq's divided
parliament called for a vote to expel US
troops and promise to schedule an
extraordinary session to the debate,
the matter parlor. I think that they'd
taken control of their country. Again,
parliament must clearly an
urgently express its view
about the ongoing American
violations of Iraq.
Sovereignty. Said Salaam,
I'll Shamira a lawmaker
loyal to the populace cleric
mock Tada Owl Satta through
the fucking balls you have over there to
be any sort of a leader of men. I mean,
you're really,
I mean,
I hope what they're doing over there
works because what we're doing is not
stopping terrorism. Maybe it's
stopping it from coming over here.
I don't fucking know. But all I
know is when I look at the ledger,
uh, you know, we're,
we're fucking bankrupt.
We just keep raising our amount of debt.
Why don't we fucking good back here?
Get back here. Bring the
fucking kids home. All right.
Fucking get on.
Get into this electrical shit.
I didn't give a shit if it hurts the
environment more just like so he can,
we can pay this shit off.
All right.
With the money we make from exporting
all the weed that we're growing,
the God damn it. If I can figure out
how to solve the world's problems, kids,
somebody in a suit and tie a,
all right,
let's see what's going on in Germany.
That's my first stop.
Germany army could recruit EU
citizens. Ah, for fuck sakes. It just,
Jeremy,
they really doing this again.
Okay.
All right. Slowly loading.
Slowly, slowly loading.
It is really bizarre how Europe,
if they're not unified, they did.
They just fucking, they will start
a world war, you know? I know.
Then what do we get? We get shit for
border. What's the worst thing we did?
We get fat.
Is that all we're doing a Nobel,
I think you're doing a little more than
that in the world are right. All right.
German army could recruit EU citizens
seven years after Germany scrapped
conscription, whatever the fuck that
it, it's defense chief has said,
employing EU citizens is an
option to fill expert posts.
Army general inspector Ybor hard Zorn.
Okay.
Said the forces had to
lock, handle, sorry.
Lock look in all direction in times
of lack of qualified personnel such as
doctors and it specialists.
Oh Wow.
Have they outsourced all their shit in
their country to the armed forces have
been beset by years of underinvestment.
Germany aims to increase its military
by 21,000 personnel by 2025 well,
what the fuck are they getting ready for?
Ah,
Jesus Christ. Oh Man. You know,
this is why you don't read World News.
This is why you just sit around and you
try and find a new sport that you can
get involved in.
All right, let me, let me do the one
read here for this week. All right,
and by the way,
my little thing for my headphones came.
I just have to go pick it up. Um,
all right, let's get over here.
Um, by the way, made it through
Christmas. What's up without Busan?
33 fucking days in 33 days in.
I'm going to go to the rose bowl sober
and then I'm going to go on my tour and I
am going to be fucking ready.
Bay Baby,
a butcher box.
Everybody
butcher box delivers healthy.
100% grass fed and grass
finished beef free range.
Organic chicken and heritage. Bread. Pork,
the greatest pork chop I've ever cooked.
Yeah.
MMM.
The incredible quality of butcher box
meets starts with the commitment to
raising animals humanely and
free of antibiotics and hormones.
They rub their bellies
before they murdered them.
Cook with the peace of mind knowing
you're eating holiday, high quality meat,
grass fed and grass finished products.
These aren't pigs eat nother fucking
pigs like the God damn animals in this
country. The hell. See it's choice
you can make for your family.
Each box comes with at least
eight to 11 pounds of meat meat,
which is enough for 24
individual size meals.
You can choose from five
different box types. All beef.
All right?
Okay.
All be for the racist, uh,
beef and chicken for somebody.
Every once in a while we'll bang
somebody outside their race. Uh,
beef and pork old school,
a mixed box for the liberal
custom box for a, the Dean del Rey,
right? Dean del Ray likes all this shit.
Custom lets you choose your own cuts for
Free Bacon and $20 off your first box.
Go to butcher box.com/burr and
enter Promo Code burpee. You are,
are are right. That's the podcast
for this week. God bless all the, uh,
have a great weekend.
You can't
see on Monday.
Uh, I guess that's it. You know,
try to get along with each other,
everyone. All right, I'll see you.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it is the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
December 27th,
2010 the final Monday of 2010. How,
what are you going to do with it?
Huh? Are you going to make this
the greatest Monday you'd like?
Don't you hate when that goes. Fucking
motivational speakers is sitting there.
You're trying to get motivated to
not be a negative con like myself,
right? And then this guy
comes out, you're getting,
you're getting all excited to fucking
have something positive be said to you.
And what does the Guy Do?
He keeps,
he gets you all nervous with
this fucking ridiculous,
heightened sense of urgency
for just a regular fucking day.
This is Monday. Think about that.
If you buddy, this is Monday,
December 27th,
2010.
Does anybody know what that means? Well,
I mean there's no history. Don't you hit,
that's the worst part too.
When they start acting like somebody else.
Talk to them. Well, John,
there's no historical, uh,
thingamajig for December 27th. This
is just a regular day. Think about 10.
If you buddy,
it's just a regular day.
Is this just a regular shirt and my,
just a regular person.
Is that how I'm going to live my
life right there. Fucking Bam.
Blow his fucking brains out right
there. See, it wasn't a regular Monday.
You're fucking Douche.
It was a Monday you died because no
one wants to hear your current speech.
All right. I think I've said
58 times already. Um, anyways,
it's December 27th, two days up to
Christmas. It's 72 motherfucking days.
And to me not drinking, I can need
five more days. No, four more days.
And I break my record for uh,
you know,
being sober. I'm going for a hundred
days and uh, it's good. It's going good.
Oh yeah, I'm having a great
fucking time. Uh, Jesus. Um,
anyways. Did you guys have
yourself a merry little Christmas?
Do you have a good Christmas? Did you
get the things that you wanted? Um,
I had a fucking awesome Christmas once
I was able to finally relax cause uh,
people out there who do the
road truckers are the comedians,
lounge singers actually
lounge singers don't travel.
That just stuck at that same
fucking place. You know,
like Jack Nicholson in the movie, the
shining just slowly going fucking crazy.
Playing handball off the wall of
their red roof inn. Fucking sweet.
Um, yeah, when you travel as much as I do,
uh, your brain, I dunno,
it can't slow down at the needs
like four or five days to slow down.
And uh,
you can't sit down on a couch
and a lay down on a bed for like,
at least I can't feel
like more than 10 minutes.
Your brain is just fucking go and go
and go and go and go. And, and uh,
it took me like four or five days and
then I was finally able to relax and in a,
and enjoy the holiday. I actually a,
I was so wound up from doing the road.
I actually wanted to be a,
wanted to be alone.
Don't, even though I didn't want
to be alone, it's Christmas.
I don't want to be alone, but I did. I
just didn't want to deal with any sort of,
uh, people. And I've discovered
when you become an adult,
truly become an adult is a
Christmas is not about you anymore.
It's about making sure everyone
around you had a great Christmas.
And then after all the frenzy is
sitting back and your enjoyment is that
everyone around you had a great Christmas.
And I finally figured that
out this year. And, uh,
I became a jolly son of a bitch.
I really enjoyed my Christmas,
you know,
and I got to admit,
on December 26th yesterday I went out
and bought something that I wanted.
Um,
um,
gradually putting together
a John Bonam fucking,
uh,
I don't know if I'm going at out as,
as him on Halloween or a fun fucking,
uh,
gonna make a stupid youtube video.
I don't know what,
but I'm gradually putting together shit
that looks like stuff that he wore.
And a, I can grow a beard. I'll dye
it brown. We'll see what happens.
You know what I bought? I bought his
Adidas sneakers that he wore at the, uh,
the Seattle concert.
And you know,
you're a fucking John Bonham freak
for those of you weren't in a music.
John Bonham is the greatest fucking
drummer I ever heard, you know? Um,
just as far as the shit that I
like, I know you can say, oh,
Max Roach and all those fucking guys.
Who Buddy rich.
I'm not trying to be a dick
here. All right. But like,
except for the kids who think Neil Peart
is better than John Bonam. All right.
And if you think that you
are a monotone jackass, um, all right.
But anyways, yeah, if you go
on youtube and you look up, uh,
it's actually Moby Dick rare
clip and it's him in Seattle.
And at that point they weren't
calling it Moby Dick Anymore.
They will calling it, uh, I something,
I guess over the top because Robert
Plant Goes Joan Henry bottom over the top
and then they got like
this, this, this 1970s, uh,
what is it fucking technology where
it goes over the top, top, top weight.
You know, it's supposed to be
like blowing people's minds.
And if you look at the arrogant way,
Robert Plant walks away from the mic.
You really want to throw something at
the back of his bushy head. But, uh,
if you watch John Bonam play, he's got a
pair of I believe, uh, the Adidas dragons.
Huh? Anybody old out there? Remember
that deed is dragon's Adidas country, uh,
the Adidas dragons.
So I have those and all I need is a pair
of white fucking pants and they sell a
replica. That tee shirt that he
wore in the song remains the same.
So right there I got the fucking outfit.
Then I've got to do is just get
a wig and I'm good to go. Uh,
maybe I'll do that for you guys next
year. I'll make a fucking off. You know,
there'll be a riot.
I should do that and not
say it's me and I'll,
I'll just put a youtube video up and
it'll be John Bonam cover and I'll butcher
it, one of his songs. And you guys
can all laugh at how bad people trash
for actually buying the entire
outfit. I'm not above it, dude.
I am a total fucking music geek like that.
I will actually buy some.
Speaking of that, I want to
recommend a book here before I am.
I don't know if I've even said anything
funny other than revealing how fucking
pathetic my personal life
is. Um, what do I got here?
Um,
out of all the led Zepplin books out
there and there's a zillion of them and
they're all fucking
ridiculous for the most part.
They always have them selling their soul
to the devil and Jimmy Page muttering
some sort of a cult bullshit walking away.
Um,
you know of them fucking sticking
a flounder in some girls Twat,
which probably happened in Seattle.
I have no fucking idea. But, uh,
the best book that I
have found on it is a,
it's called John Bonam,
the powerhouse behind led Zeppelin
and it's written by his brother,
Mick bottom.
And it says right on the back,
or is it on the inside cover? Why he
wrote the book? He basically says,
if I can just paraphrase here,
why don't I just,
I'll read you a little excerpt about
10 years ago. This is from his brother,
um, after, oh actually,
Linda Bonham wrote this about 10 years
ago after reading yet another load of
rubbish about his brother John.
My husband mic turned to me and said,
I should write a book about our kid,
if only to tell Zoho John's daughter
what a great bloke your dad was.
And with that, the seeds of this
book began to grow and it's fuck,
it's just a killer book. It's very,
very little of it is actually about,
you know, all the bullshit that those
other books are about, which is, you know,
and then they went to this town and they
drank this much and they did this and
they did that. It's, it's really, uh,
him growing up with John and John
being home in between the tours and,
uh, it's fucking awesome. I read
it in like a day and a half,
two days.
But when do you expect that considering
I basically expose myself to be like
that chick who whacks Selena. You
know, you know that fucking psycho,
uh, Jesus Christ's of John Bonham
was alive. What I be stocking him.
This is really getting creepy. All right,
let's, let's fucking plow ahead yet,
but I want to recommend that
book. All right. In this
big words and lots of pages,
by big words,
I mean big font,
lots of pictures and um,
yeah, definitely check it
out. Definitely check it out.
And a classic Englishman,
I can tell you that about John
Bonham in that like most Englishman,
he looks like he never
lifted a weight in his life.
Got that awful fish and chip torso yet
continued to wear tight shirts right
through this career. Never understand
that. You only see that you don't,
you do not see that here in America,
except with gay guys.
Gay guys will wear tight shirts no matter
what shape the rent. That's not true.
They will actually, if long as they
got a little peck action going on,
they don't give a fuck about this stomach.
You know that as long as that chest is
out a little bit further than the stomach,
they wear tight shirts too. But I've
been over to Europe and I'm telling you,
I've never seen it.
Like you can never did a
pushup and their fucking lives,
those types of bodies.
You got that seventh grade chest
and arms and then this fucking,
I just drank a keg of beer
stomach and uh, this, you know,
this is like, you know what
it is? This is like they,
they made it big before Elvis fucking
died in Elvis is the first behind the
music as far as the rock star and
all that to, I know every one guy,
he stole all the music from the Blues
and Gospel Black Dudes. You know what?
Go Fuck Yourself. So sick of
that stupid ass fucking argument.
He didn't, he was influenced by him,
but because he's a different race,
they said he stole it. It's
such bullshit. You know,
if you're black and you listen to
a blues guy and you play blues,
you're carrying on a tradition. But if
you're white, you do it. You stealing.
All right, in a black dude fucking a
steel white music, they're sampling.
It's bullshit. It's all bullshit.
Nobody's stealing from anybody.
You're year of being influenced so
enough already with the fucking whining.
I'm so sick of fucking people pitching
that this unfair business is unfair.
Yes. Show businesses on fair
if life is unfair. Oh really?
Did you write it and then
you didn't get credit? Well,
fucking welcome to the club.
I never wrote anything that
I need to get credit for it,
but I can tell you right now, I have
been a victim of some very creative math.
Yeah. You know what, Bill,
here's your royalty checks. Uh,
that's $4 and 98 cents.
Yeah.
We had a hundred grand
worth of white out that we,
and we had to buy a new typewriter
that costs us 30 grand, you know,
and all that comes out of your fucking
pocket. Yeah. It's been going on forever.
But the reason why I say,
uh,
Elvis is the original behind the music
is because he's the first guy who got as
far as I can tell, got lofted all
the way up into the stratosphere.
And uh, like everything he did
now is just so fucking cliche,
but he was the first guy doing it. So
nobody could really see it, you know,
and by the time he died as a drug
drug addicted fat fuck on a toilet,
that was 77, you know,
at which point, you know,
[inaudible] was approaching 30 years of
age. They were, it was already too late.
Right. Does that make any fucking sense?
I'm trying to, I'm trying to justify,
and this is also before,
like John Bonham never would have got
that if he was living today. I, I can,
I can't guarantee that
he wouldn't be dead,
but he definitely would have like a
95% chance and not being dead because
someone would be like, you know, say you
had a problem. That'd be an intervention.
And then also when he got out of shape
and he started getting the man tits there,
they, they, they fucking,
he would've got the ship teased out of
him on youtube and just start a sheer
fucking humiliation. Uh, I think
you would have done some setups,
but you never know.
He is European and they just really don't
seem to be into physical fitness over
there.
This is coming from an American,
they're not obese,
but they are just some fleshy mushy sons
of bitches over there. Not all of them.
Not all.
You get your occasional one,
but they'll the occasional ones seems
like the ones that are born that way.
You know, like the dad was like a
fucking ship builder and his dad was the,
you know, fucking work with Thor or some
shit. You know what I mean? On a fucking,
now what? What am I talking
about here? Really? People. Huh?
13 minutes of absolute shit.
All right, let's, what,
what are we going to talk
about this week here? Um, oh,
you guys want to hear a story?
Because when his story here do you got,
you have to, do you actually have to
work right now? Does anybody know?
Does anybody working right now?
Does anybody have such a fucking Dick
for a boss that he basically gave you new
year's Eve off and then Christmas
Day off and now it's Monday.
Now you're back to work. You know, this
is a really, I don't know about you guys,
but this is one of the most depressing
weeks of the year, you know,
is the week between Christmas and
New Year's. Once Christmas is over,
you know, it's like you see the
buildup of the tree. First of all,
you get your Christmas
tree and if you're like me,
everybody trashes the tree except for
this guy here who writes me this letter.
Hey Bill, fuck the haters. Fuck
the haters. Your tree is awesome.
Your tree is a noble fir,
which is a far superior tree compared
to those faggoty Douglas firs.
I love of this guy made to leak
just those trees are gay. Um,
anyways, where the hell am I?
Yes, they look a little sparse,
but there is actually room
to hang the ornaments.
I like to joke that most people decorate
their Christmas bushes by just throwing
shit at them and hoping for the best ever.
Notice all the ends of the branches
of Douglas Firs are freshly cut.
A Douglas firs do not
grow in a conical shape.
That means Christmas tree shape.
I guess they have to be trimmed in
order to look like a tree because they
normally look like a bush. Exactly. That's
why I never liked those fucking trees.
It looks like a shrub.
I've never seen a fucking tree looked
like a Christmas tree. That's why.
And that's why I liked the tree that I
bought because it looked like a fucking
tree. Thank you sir. Um, he said,
have you ever seen how they prune these
trees on the farm before this ship to
your local grocery store parking lot?
A dude would dude with the hedge
clipper tied to his back at an angle,
goes up and down the roads of
bushes and walks around each one,
cutting it into a Christmas tree shape.
Nobles aren't artificially shaped at
all and grow to be symmetrical and
perfectly proportioned. There
you go. So go fuck yourself.
They also had somebody else write me a
letter saying that fuck all those people
by, uh, my sister or somebody
is uh, ah, fuck, I wish I saved.
This is in, in some sort of artistic
design or something to like my Theresa.
You know what? I'm a little ahead
of the curve people you way,
you know what's going to happen.
One of these fucking emaciated celebrities
is going to get one and then it's
going to become all the rage thing.
We wearing uggs with the fucking
Santa Claus Thong, right?
With the midriff showing be like Anna God.
Like oh my God,
this tree is like Anna God and they're
going to be in US magazine and that's
going to be it. Matthew mcconaughey
will be naked playing bongos. Um,
and it'll all work out, but you will
remember that you heard it here first.
You heard it here first. I actually bought
a fucking tree. You guys bought shrubs.
All right, so fuck you and your
holiday. Um, but anyways, yeah,
it's a really depressing week.
So anyways,
you go out and you buy the God damn tree.
So then you have the tree and as the
excitement of the smell of the tree,
it smells like Christmas. All my
God, it's got to happen, right?
It's that time of year. We're going to
actually get off the wheel for a second.
Joy, the people around us, hopefully,
you know. And then what happened?
And you decorate the tree,
you put a little skirt around it,
you dress up that little whore,
right?
You get even more excited that one app.
But you come home for work and one of
your family members of the person you live
with has wrapped a couple of gifts putting
in underneath. This is the buildup,
right? This is Elvis, 1954
right? For 40 fucking hit.
You know, and then what
happens? A couple more gifts.
So he puts on a fucking Christmas record.
Your balls have filled up just
waiting to fucking for Christmas Day.
And then Christmas comes,
alright,
Elvis on the fucking Ed Sullivan show.
Everybody's going fucking crazy people
opening gifts is fucking bitches
screaming outside your window.
You throw down a scarf at him,
everything is fucking great.
And then just like dad, it's
over. It's fucking over.
You know, you get drafted,
send you over to Jeremy.
I can't do this Elvis thing I
don't fucking own saying here.
You know what I mean? Dennis fucking
over. They need looking at your tree.
You know, it's still got the lights, it
still has to skirt. But what happened?
All the gifts, they're all God. You
know, it was a couple of pieces of paper.
It's like they peaked.
It's like your favorite band.
They had those three awesome albums in
a row and now they're about ready to
fucking spend their rest of their career,
trying to recapture those, the, the, the,
whatever the fuck they did in those
three albums. Right. And then that's it.
So over to say goodbye to everybody.
You start looking at your family members.
You see him there a year older.
She makes you feel older. Yeah. No,
nothing's on TV.
All the TV people are on vacation.
This show in something on a loop.
Mtvs finally showing fucking videos.
He gets quiet. You sit back and
reflect on what a nice Christmas it is,
but you just can't get over this feeling
of this wave of depression that's
coming because you know it's
about radius start all over again.
Another fucking year
with this fucking job,
with that fucking Douche
telling me what to do.
My fucking by fan, he a fucking
girlfriend or your wife or your husband.
It's going to be another fucking year.
You know
the edge of fucking tree,
just reminding you of your God damn
mortality because you're not, you're not,
you're not fucking water in it.
The way you watered it before Christmas.
You skip a few days,
branches start to droop,
couple start to turn brown
like the gray and your hair.
Look at this artistic little,
jot them on here,
you know,
and by the t and then what's the worst is
then you start walking down the street,
going out to your car and what happens
to body start piling up out there.
You see your first fucking Christmas tree,
that Bah humbug Douche
bag across the street.
Who throws the fucking thing out
at like one o'clock in the morning,
December 26th and it's sitting out there,
right laying on its side like a fucking
victim at the beginning of the first 48
you know,
just got one little piece of tensile
blowing in the wind because the rest of
it's shit got snatched off from around
it's fucking neck. Just lay there.
Dead is a fucking door.
Doornail next day you come out,
there's two more.
Start driving down the work.
And you just see them all over the
place. Just being the positive, you know,
like fucking former stars and boy bands
just littering the fucking highway and
it's fucking over this fucking over.
So what do you do then?
He got what?
You got New Year's eve coming up the
worst fucking holiday of the year.
You know, New Year's Eve is for young
people. It's not for old people.
You know,
that's when you know,
you've hit a level of maturity is when
you can go to bed at like 10 o'clock,
10:00 PM on New Year's eve and you
didn't go out. You didn't get drunk.
He stayed away from those fucking morons.
You know,
I'd say what's a great weekend to go out
as the weekend after New Year's eve and
all those guys who,
people are still fucking hung over
and they're still fucking sick,
you know,
from their overindulgent cause they
don't know how to drink and eat.
Then you head out, like I'll
tell you what's it, you know,
it's gonna be a great night. Uh, what's,
what's New Year's? He Friday night.
You want to be a great night to go out
drinking Monday night that my friends
will be a great God damn night. If you're
an antisocial fucking prick like I am,
that's, that's where you want to go. Um,
oh hey. Speaking of which, listen
to this shit. Me and Paul Versey,
we're coming down to the wire here.
We're actually tied. All right.
As of right before this weekend,
we are tight.
All right.
And I got to tell you something this
week I had a breakthrough in my gambling.
We picked four games a week.
Whoever wins it in the end,
it's only a hundred bucks,
but it's,
it's more just about the shit
talk and during the year, um,
so this year nobody has gone
undefeated yet. All right,
so you're talking 16 weeks ago gambling
32 weeks between the two of us,
nobody has gone for no,
we've had a, you know,
a number of three in ones,
but nobody has gone for an hour.
And a Paul Versey actually
did the impossible.
What do we called the
unthinkable and the unimaginable,
the unimaginable is going for no,
he did the unthinkable. He went,
oh and for so this week I don't
know what I was talking to one,
a knee,
his uncles and uh,
he was talking about going against public
opinion and there was this whole new
website and shit about going against
public opinion with your gambling.
And I decided to take a
little bit of that. All right,
cause this is,
this is what I realized the reason why
I could never break through three in one
and get to foreign no,
is because I kept picking people that I
thought were going to win every fucking
game. And I know that sounds crazy,
but to gamblers, that makes sense.
You know,
when you don't have money on the game,
you can actually sit there and fucking,
you know,
just say,
you know what?
Not only do I think this team's
going to cover the spread.
I think they're going
to win the fucking game.
But all of a sudden when you put money
on it, you alligator arm it and you,
you just start,
you know,
you get too scared to take a
fucking chance. At least I did.
So this week I was like, fuck it.
I'm taking a couple of chances here.
All right. I went to safe. At first,
I picked Tampa over Seattle
and that dockers wearing
fucking coaching staff with
Pete Carroll. I said, fuck
it. I'm going with Tampa now.
That was one that I was, that
was my plane. It's safe. Bet.
And then I don't know,
I was looking at Washington and
Jacksonville and I was like, you know,
it's in Jacksonville.
Jacksonville's going to win that.
You know they're going to win this game.
They're going to get the running game
going. They are going to fucking run over.
They got fucking rex Grossman
playing quarterback for Washington.
It's fucking over. But I don't
know why. I got a feeling
I got to feel and fucking Washington
is going to win this game just because
nobody thinks they're going to. So I
said, fuck it. I've bet on Washington,
you know?
And then continuing that line of thought
San Diego was going into Cincinnati.
Cincinnati is shit,
the bed the entire fucking year.
San Diego always plays well in December.
They're a heckle, a heckle and Jeckle.
Oh, fucking a, what do you call it?
Jekyll and Hyde. Fucking a
team. And I said to hell with
that, I don't give a shit.
I'm going with Cincinnati. And Lo and
behold, yours truly with three and Oh,
yesterday three and Paul
Versey went one and two.
We had the Sunday night game,
but it got fucking snowed out.
I won game up on them. I'm sorry. We're
not tied. I am one game up on him.
All right. So I went through, you
know, yesterday he went one and two.
So matter what happens tonight,
you know,
if I lose my game, he, he wins his game.
I'm going to be up by two games
with one week to go. All right?
But if I win tonight and
go foreign over four, no,
I will have done the unimaginable.
I'll, I'll done it. And who do you think
I took tonight? Who would you take?
The spread is two and a half falcons at
home playing the saints. Who Do you like?
Who Do you like?
12 and two is that what a,
is that what the Falcons are Matty ice
at home? Just given two and a half.
It's their fucking year.
I said fuck it.
I'm taking the saints.
It took the saints and the points with
drew Brees sticking with line of thought
of going against the,
playing it safe. I think a,
I don't think the falcons had
been tested yet this year and uh,
I just think that,
you know,
this is just going to be one of those
things that happens to a team like this.
I still think they might be a year
away from doing something huge.
And this is one of these games where I
just think they're going to get a wake up
call.
Like okay,
we're good but we s we but like we're
not like the saints that actually have
gone through the whole thing
on one of the super bowl.
That's why I took the saints
I'm looking to go for, no,
Paul Versey has got the
now Tuesday night game.
He took the Minnesota Vikings getting
14 points and a, I'm telling you,
if I go for no and he goes one and three,
I'll pick up three games.
I'll be up for games with one
week to go and we pick four games.
All have to do is fucking win one game.
It's a goddamn extra point.
It's a chip shot and I will get bragging
rights for the entire fucking year and
I will really be excited about that.
And with that,
so they go for all of these though,
all of you who are into the gambling
aspects of my life and I with that,
somebody actually came up with this
awesome theory, um, about sports.
Uh, this guy says, Bill, I have,
I have a theory about sports that tends
to piss people off, especially women,
which makes me think I'm onto something.
And it's got nothing to do with
the unpredictability of sports.
I think he's this, this, this, this theory
is basically why people like sports.
He said it mainly applies,
um, to team sports.
Some individual sports
too. Okay. So here it is.
It begins back in the day when armies
were in the field waiting to go into
battle and armies objective
was essentially to conquer
foreign lands and rape
women in order to celebrate
the glory of their race slash,
culture and they would train
for battles by making up games.
These games were based around
themes of land grabbing and raping.
In this theory, the ball,
football, basketball,
whatever represents the seed,
the goals,
either posts or a hoop or a net represents
the opposing team's women symbolizing
either their legs up in the air or
their vantage or their womb, whatever.
The opposing team represents the enemy
army and the objective of the game is to
get your seed past the opposition
and impregnate their women.
That's essentially the theory and it's
a abridged version and it's why some
sports are like cracked and some are
just who gives a shit when a sport is put
together. Right. It's a primal
source of highly addictive goodness.
Did you ever think somebody who would
like basically compare sports to rape with
then you know if you
were going to do that,
you wouldn't think that they would
basically. Then just say yeah, and it's,
you think that there would be trashing it.
Not saying that it's a,
that it's a form of highly
addictive goodness. So there you go.
Actually look that theory. I believe in
that. All that subliminal Shit, you know,
and uh, yeah, I'll go with deck. What
do you guys think about that dairy?
My the worst. MERV Griffin
ever. I have no studio audience.
What do you guys think into the abyss?
Um,
am I really going to do another
fucking, I got to, I got to be, uh,
I gotta be balanced here, fair and
balanced when it comes to the sports shit,
as it's becoming too much sports. I
got to, Oh, here's one for you. I,
but I tell you, I was, I said I forgot.
I was going to tell you a story here. Uh,
I took cleo out.
Uh,
we went outside for a walk so she could
do her business and I'm walking up the
street and I went around
the corner and Cleo is a,
you know, she's going, number
one, she's taken a piss.
So I'm standing there, right? And I,
I looked and I see this guy
as Cleo is beginning to do,
her thing is walking to his SUV,
like one of those little mini ones,
like the Lexus sorta one. And I see him
looking at me, I just sort of look back.
I didn't think anything of it. And cleo
is going in the bathroom and I'm going,
that's a good girl. Good
girl. She'll go grow.
You go to a bat boy as you go girl,
I'm doing that shit right.
Slapping her on her fucking
muscular thighs and you know,
she finishes does a Little Harlem
shake, you know, and then she fought,
we start fucking uh,
walking up the street and then I said,
the guy down at the SUV,
he all of a sudden you just say this,
pick it up dude. I'm like, what?
This dude pick it up.
I go and I realized he touched,
he took his shit, which she
didn't. I go, she went number one.
I can't believe I said that, but I wonder
when the argument, I would be like,
she took a pith and
when she went number one
and then the guy just gets in his
fucking car such that getting this,
it is little SUV thing. I go, what?
No, sorry. You Go. So I said sorry.
Yeah,
not as loud as you said that other shit.
Then he got in his car
and he fucking drove away.
It's one thing I fucking hate about the
west coast is the way they confront you.
The confrontation out here. I don't
know why they do it like back east.
They would have been like, hey dude,
fucking Nino. Pick up your shit.
You know out here. And so he's
like, I don't know what it is.
They always calling you bro.
Hey Bro, what's up dude?
Pick it up. Deved just fucking
annoys the shit out of me.
It just fucking annoying.
I don't know.
That's the only time it really bugs me
being out here is that that that surfer
fucking way that they talk when
they think they confront you,
Bro. What a Douche. And you know,
what kills me is that that affected,
that affected me the way
I interacted with people,
you know,
for like the next four hours.
I just had that playing in a
loop in my head, pick it up.
It was in my fucking
head everywhere I went
when paper or plastic, you know, just
it's, you know, all he had pickup deed.
I'm just fucking here that in my head.
And uh,
what did you know what I mean?
The proper way to do that is
just to be like, excuse me.
Did, did your dog just, uh,
go number two and then not all she went,
number one, it'd be like, okay, I'm sorry.
It's just lately people are leaving.
Okay. That's the way you do it. You know,
just go pick it up, dude. Fucking,
ah,
I wish I could train cleo.
You know,
for those of you new to my podcast,
she is a pit bull to just
do a mock charge. You know,
they do that in the wild.
I just wished it just teeth
or I just fucking run,
just have that guide p
his slacks a little bit.
And then right to the point where he
thought he was going to get his fucking
balls ripped off,
she just stops on a dime.
It turns around and this fucking runs
up the beautiful way that she runs.
I should take a video of
my dog running full speed.
It's one of the most beautiful things
you ever gonna to see. It's literally,
you could make like one of those
secretary movies, this fucking dog,
she is shredded
I and like she should,
she's awesome. And the way she runs
the level of power, first of all,
when she runs,
she gets like excited right before she
does and she does this move where she
sorta throws her head back a little
bit and just throws her [inaudible].
It's like, it's like a fucking
muscle car. It's unbelievable.
Absolutely loved watching her run.
And if I could just somehow train her
to run and scare the shit out of people
who say pick it up, deed, that
would really make me happy.
So, uh, that's what happened this week.
And then I went inside and that ended up
getting into an argument with Nia cause
I was just in a bad
fucking mood. Uh, no did I,
now she got mad at me
about something else.
She was really pissed at me this
week. I don't what the fuck, you know,
one of those deals.
I think it was cause I was coming down
off being off the on the road and she
thought that I was going
to be a dick. And, uh,
no matter how many times I tell
her that I have to, you know,
I need a few days to unwind.
Like I literally have the urge when I'm
in the house to get up and just get in
the car and just start driving around
because I'm so in travel mode and go and
go and go and go and go and that it,
uh, it takes a fucking minute. So,
uh, you know, I don't know. I don't
know if I've got to do yoga or whatever.
I have no fucking idea. It's
definitely seems to be causing a rift.
Um,
but anyways, I just remembered
I was going to tell you, oh,
I know last night I went and I saw the
fighter starring Mark Wahlberg and a
Christian Bale, and I can't
recommend that movie highly enough.
That movie was fucking awesome. It was
a movie I wasn't going to see. I'm like,
Oh God, here we go. Rocky all over again.
But what saved it was, it was Micky ward.
And,
uh,
I remember his fights and I'm embarrassed
to said I didn't see that Arturo Gotti
fight until years afterwards.
I actually watched it on Youtube and
I remember Colin Quinn coming into the
cellar raving about that fight.
Um,
in fact, there's two fights that
I remember that I was just like,
I have to see this fight.
It was the Micky ward,
Arturo Gotti fight after hearing Colin
Quinn Rave about it down at the comedy
cellar. And, uh,
the Diego Cora, uh, corrals, fights.
Uh, was it corrals? Casteel fight
is, that's what was, yes. Diego,
I can't fucking remember. She can
tell. I dip in and out of boxing,
but, uh, that's a crap corrals.
Casteel their first fucking
fight is unbelievable.
And Charlie Murphy flipped out about
that when he told me he almost broke his
foot at the end of that fight.
Well, one of them is just, you know,
knocked out, gets up
in this training, goes,
you better fucking get
inside now cause everything,
I think I told this story before you guys,
you better fucking get inside now when
he put his mouthpiece in him and uh,
he turned around, they continue
the round, he fucking knocks.
The other guy technically knocks
out the other fucking guy.
And I guess that got Charlie
so fucking amped up. He,
he stomped his foot down on the
floor and woke up his whole family.
So those are the two fights. But
anyway, so this fight, uh, this,
this movie is about a Micky Ward's,
uh,
you know, ascension up to trying
to win a championship. And,
uh, I have to tell you, man,
it is absolutely phenomenal.
I was rooting for like the Mark Walberg
character while he was fighting.
It was fucking awesome. Maybe want to
get in great shape. And I gotta tell you,
I don't think I've ever seen a movie
where they did the Boston accent better.
You even just for that reason,
even if you're not a sports fan,
you got to go see there and see the
five women that play his sister's stiff.
They're fucking unbelievable.
And it reminded me of this period in my
life when I was underage and I used to
go out to these dive bars in like Chelsea
and all those awful m towns north of
Boston, Malden, Medford reveal.
I used to go out to all of those places
because they didn't give a fuck cause
most of them were actually, you know,
you know, people were doing coke,
it was the 80s now some
people was selling coke.
So like alcohol just
seemed like it was a joke.
It's like somebody went up there and
asked for some juice so I could actually
get served my fucking 12 year
old boy ish face. And um,
those five women that you see,
uh,
in, in, in that movie that those are
the kinds of girls that you ran into.
They will like 21 years old.
And they look like they were 40.
They already had a kid and they
were jaded. I can't explain it.
And so fucked up was, it
was a, it was like a 20,
25 minute ride from where I lived,
which was a world away with no traffic.
Of course with traffic, it took like
a fucking hour to get there. But uh,
yeah, I just remember shooting the
shit with them and they'd be, oh,
you like smash.
But anyways,
those are my two recommendations for this
week. Get up, get the book John Bonham,
the powerhouse behind led
Zeppelin by Mick Bonham and uh,
go see the fighter.
I'm going to see true grit this week
and if someone's trying to talk me into
going to see Toronto, but I, I just, I
could give a shit about science fiction.
I've never been into it. I
never liked star trek. I,
I liked star wars for maybe six months
in my youth just because everybody else
liked it and I wanted to fit
in. So I kinda got into by
just, I don't give a shit.
I think those movies, they're
gay, they're gay. All right there.
I said it all right.
You know,
you've put on the afterburners,
oh,
I'm doing the best I can hit warp speed
and this stupid fucking handshakes,
Eh,
and the,
the aliens that they're friends with
and the gay names of the fucking space
ships that they ride around
in. And it's just, it's, it's,
it's for nerds. It's for people who
don't know how to get laid. I don't know.
That's not true, but it just, the
stereotype is true. And speaking of which,
I wanted to read this, this
overrated for this week when, um,
it's just reminded me of this.
Somebody wrote overrated Las Vegas.
Somebody wrote a, I'm tired of everybody
going to Las Vegas all the time.
They throw that shit around.
Like they're going like,
they're getting a free trip
to a space station. Like, Yo,
anybody want to go to Vegas this
weekend? Like, it's just the wildest,
craziest place.
It's not Vegas fucking stinks.
It's really not that big a deal
there. It's too hot. The drive sucks.
How do they not widen out that 14?
It's actually the 15 or whatever
to be more than two lanes. Yeah,
that's the highway. And when you come
back on Sunday, it's a fucking nightmare.
Always flying to Vegas.
Never drive unless you plan on leaving at
two in the fucking morning. He said, uh,
the other big thing I'm tired of with
Vegas is the media perception that it's
the craziest place on earth that you never
know what kind of nutty shit is going
on.
And it's like that every day of the year.
You should just go wild there.
Go home with three strippers,
party like crazy with your boys and
wake up with the most insane story ever.
It's like that the hangover.
It's like that Song Waking Up in
Vegas from Katy Perry. Woohoo. Yay.
Let's go crazy. Um, well I'm
sorry to burst your bubble.
That doesn't really happen there folks.
The 50s and 60s or over,
not much that that's hip and
happening goes on there. Uh,
you don't see Sinatra and dean coming
out to deal blackjack and drink with the
common folk unless you're bringing
in sick a six figure salary.
It's actually pretty mundane.
It's mostly full of sad old people
blowing their social security,
her social security checks on slot
machines and shit and lousy food and ugly
tourists with their stupid kids placed
the places like Disneyland with gambling
and God help you.
If you wake up with a hangover,
it's generally 117 fucking degrees out.
You walk out of Your Hotel and God,
Vegas is not supposed to be. It's supposed
to be this out of control party place.
It's not.
You want a story?
Give Charles Manson a tab of acid and a
meat cleaver and let them loose on the
strip on a Friday night. You'll have
a crazy Vegas story. Fuck that place.
All right,
well sir,
I 100% agree and disagree
all at the same time. See,
what you did is you went there and you
just looked at what you saw like I did
the first time I went there.
I walked there and I was all
dressed up to do my shows,
like I was going to be in the fucking
rat pack and I saw all these fucking fat
tourists with their flip flops and
going, wow, Vegas is dead. It isn't.
You just don't know where to look.
First of all,
you ever see those pretty girls playing
slots, you know, and you're like,
why is that pretty girl all
by herself playing slots?
How come she doesn't have a boyfriend?
That's because she's a hooker, sir.
You want to have your crazy fucking day.
You go right there.
Did you like me? First Time I went to
Vegas, I thought a hooker was, you know,
standing on a street corner snapping
her gum. Hey, like that was a hooker.
All right. But no, they, they, they're
not supposed to be in the casino,
but they look the other way.
All right.
And I was actually at a bar
one time and Jimmy Dore told,
and I'm sitting there hitting on this
girl and Bill Jimmy finally came out and
goes, Bill, what the fuck are you doing? I
was like, what? This girl's hot. He goes,
dude, you're hitting on a
hooker. And I was like, she's
a hooker. And he goes, yes.
And then all of a sudden it was like the
Matrix. I could see it. And then I went,
oh, she's a hooker. There's a
hooker, there's a regular girl,
regular girl hooker. And you all of
a sudden you could fucking see it.
Your problem is you don't know how
to see it yet. Put it this way.
I just did a road gig with somebody and
he told me his story. He went to Vegas,
he won nine grand, walked up to one
of those girls, said, hey, come here.
And she stopped playing slots,
walked right over to him. He goes,
I want another girl like
you, uh, to uh, suck my dick.
Come up to a whatever,
10 52. And they did.
And they came up there and they were
gorgeous and they sucked his dick and he
came on their face and he won nine
grand that night. So they, you go,
it is a crazy, awesome fucking place
where shit can happen if you indulge.
All right. If you stand back
like a fucking, you know,
just shitting all over
the place. The, yeah,
you're not going to have a good fucking
time. It is cheesy. It is awful. Um,
there are a bunch of, you
know, they got malls there now.
They tried to appeal the families.
All of that shit definitely goes on there,
but believe me. All right. I mean,
I don't think you can go to Fox woods
and just go, hey, you and you, I mean,
I give them probably do it, but they're
going to be old ladies. Um, it even there.
I'm sure they have their hookers.
All right. But of course they do.
But I'm telling you, go there
next time you go there. Alright,
just look for those
pretty girls playing slots
and you will have an, all of a sudden
Vegas will become, they just can't show.
They can't show that in the commercial.
You know what was that Fox?
The Fox who was on that too bad.
That baby does suck my fucking Dick.
You remember that corner?
I forget how it goes.
That whole thing about being at Foxwoods,
like it's this crazy thing.
You can't show somebody when nine you
can show that then winning nine grand,
but you can't show that other
part where he goes, hey,
you find another one just like
you who's dad didn't stick around.
So now you suck Dick for living.
Get another one of those.
Come back to my room and then end
the commercial bang. Boom. Xiao was,
he fucking comes on their faces. Okay,
you're supposed to read between the lines.
All right,
so what I would do is I would stop going
to Vegas with the fucking nerds that
you're going to Vegas with. You know? I
mean you're, you're going to Vegas, dude.
You're trying to solve the
transportation problem.
You're talking about the highways. You,
you, you're not looking at the right shit,
you know? Yes. Frank and dean are
not going to be dealing pope. Yeah,
they're dead. They're
dead. Okay. Yes. Move on.
Ashton Kutcher is going to be there
dressed like James Bond taking.
I fucking hate those commercials.
I envy that guy's career. You know,
I really envy that guy's career.
He's smart. Son of a bitch.
Most people do a hit fucking
sick, common, and that's it.
He got into producing very smart guy,
but I hate those fucking commercials
with him sitting there with the stupid
cameras and everybody's just enamored
with him. Look at the guy with the camera.
Wait, we all have cameras and one in our
phone. This really isn't that exciting.
Um, so there you go. Surf. I know I
trashed you, but go to Vegas again. Okay.
Fucking pony up the fucking 70 bucks
and fly out there on southwest.
Go down to the strip. Okay, gamble.
Hopefully you win. If you don't,
you know, even if you don't,
to save a little money and have a couple
of girls blow your cum on their face
and I'm guaranteeing you,
you're going to go home with a smile,
even if you have to sit in that
traffic on the 15. Hey listen,
I know there's a lot of people listening
to this podcast and went to Vegas.
I want to hear some stories and
don't make them up. All right?
I want to get some actual goddamn stories,
okay?
And I'll see through the bullshit ones
unless you're a really good storyteller.
Okay. Because the truth
is in the details. Uh,
look at me talking shit like
fucking Rex Ryan. Oh wait a minute.
Did the jets loose again this week?
Oh, isn't that funny? Isn't that funny?
It's almost like exactly what I said
was gonna happen. Fucking happened.
You know,
and I know a lot of you guys,
you probably can't remember
cause you know, you know,
nobody can remember shit in this country.
Like I used to do a bit about
that Geico Lizard, how, you know,
everybody loves that fucking thing.
And I just look at that thing like that
thing has no credibility whatsoever.
When those commercials started
out, he's like, no, I'm a Gecko.
All right, get away from me. Fuck
you. And your insurance company.
Then all of a sudden he
liked fucking sold out.
Now he sells the insurance and
no one calls him on the bullshit.
Well this is my fucking a
Geico Gecko lizard moment.
Here's Rex Ryan.
I'll play two clips.
This is rex Ryan on hard
knocks back in August.
Let's hear what he has to
say about his football team,
which started my hatred of the
fucking jets. Here we go, everybody.
Let's turn up the volume.
Here we go.
If we play at our best,
we will be every team in this
fucking league playing at their best.
So who's it on? Whose
shoulders as it? Bob.
There you go. Could you hear that? Sorry,
I just fucked with the volume here.
Ready to crank that up. All right. That's
what he said. We will beat every team.
He played up beds. We could beat every
fucking team and his fucking league.
You know the usual bullshit. Okay.
For those of you forgot. All right.
Now here's him yesterday when they backed
into the fucking playoffs like they
did last year.
Here we go.
That's the way I think
we're in class. God, dog.
It ain't the way I wanted it,
but I'll take it.
Hello? Hello? You fucking,
yeah. What happened?
Rex fucking dope.
I swear to God was was I was.
There's no reason for me to even bring
it up, but I have to bring it up. Okay.
That's the second major thing that I
was right about in football this year,
and as much as you fucking hate
to admit it, you know I'm right.
I told you Peyton manning
was fucking overrated.
I told you it was a regular season.
Statistical Juggernaut.
He threw a pick six the lose the fucking
super bowl and he has yet to get shit
for it yet to get shit for it.
It's fucking volume is way too high.
I'm sorry, let me bring this down here.
He is yet to get shit for it. All
right, and I told you I didn't,
I didn't understand what
the jets were talking about.
I didn't understand why they felt
like they were the shit. You know,
was it last year that they made the
playoffs because the cult sat half their
fucking team wasn't it? Wasn't
it? That wasn't last year,
isn't that how they got into the fucking
playoffs then this year they come in
just talking all this shit.
Now look,
I'm not saying that they couldn't go
on any team in the NFL at this point.
If you get hot in the end of December,
you can actually go on a run and win the
fucking super bowl like the giants did.
All right,
that's another fucking hilarious thing.
The giants losing again this week and
now they're questioning whether Tom
Kauflin is worthy to coach that team,
that team,
that Amir two fucking years ago or
three years ago beat an undefeated team.
14 point underdogs.
What did the game suddenly
pass Tom Kauflin by at two
and a half fucking years.
The York, this is a different
story in New York and Boston.
Boston Jay is completely 100% negative
and they'll give you a little bit of
positive and the second they see
negative, they're like, the curse is back.
They're awful that way.
But New York,
they kind of do the ESPN thing
with a hype shit through the roof
and say this is going to be the
greatest fucking thing ever.
And then when it doesn't happen,
then they go the exact opposite way and
then it then and then just somebody is
the worst fucking thing that ever
happened in the Goddamn sport.
And that's why mediocre guys like mark,
Mark Sanchez,
who never really did anything in
fucking college foot. What did he do?
He won the fucking Rose Bowl with
that team that had won the national
championship. I know there's a turnover
of players, but give me a break.
Matt Lionheart did more than that
fucking guy and he's not even in football
anymore. I think he's playing in
like the fucking CFF CFL. Right.
So there you go. People, but
I will tell you this, I uh,
I do back Rex Ryan on
his foot fetish video.
I don't think there's anything fucking
wrong with dad. He's got a foot fetish.
He made a video. I totally agree with him.
It is a private matter and uh, you know,
the guy loves his wife.
That's what I got out of it.
I didn't think he was a Weirdo.
I think that was just one of those classic
fucking examples of every yet buddy
out there throwing sticks and
stones and all this fucking shit.
When we all have these skeletons in our,
in our closet.
Does anybody else want to turn
over their fucking hard drive,
their computer hard drive and let the
FBI go through it and look at all the
fucked up shit that you've looked at on
the internet. Give me a fucking break.
I'm a freak just like him.
I'm not into feet.
You know some of the horrific shit
that I've looked at on the internet.
I'm going to fucking judge this guy.
Then the end they, he kissed, kept going.
It's a personal matter.
I'm not going to talk about it.
You can ask me 16 ways to Sunday.
It's a personal matter and I was like,
that's exactly right, rex. It's exactly
fucking right. It's your own fucking life.
It's a personal matter. I'm not
talking about it. Go fuck yourselves.
I don't give a shit that
it's on the Internet.
It's none of your goddamn business.
Watch the video if you want.
I don't give a fuck. Then they go,
can you please talk about your wife?
And he goes, yeah, what can I say it
then with the for 23 years, I love her.
She's awesome. I was like, you
know what? This guy's a great dude.
And I realized that I was wrong saying
that he was going to make an attempt on
his life one day because he has,
because he has a great woman
in his life and that's,
that's what's holding that man
together. And uh, told you,
I told you once,
psycho can spot another psycho from
across the rumps that God blessed Rex Ryan
and his fucking foot fetish,
23 years,
he still fucking got the hots for his
wife is making freaky videos about that.
That was the shit gave me hope.
That's what it did. It gave me hope.
I don't think that guy's a freak at all.
And that's like that tiger woods shit.
And everybody sat there judging him.
Eh? People are full of Shit. You know,
just listen to that quiet voice in the
back of your head that's calling you a
hypocrite. When, when you're at the dinner
party trash and tiger woods, you know,
when you think of some
of the shit that you've,
you know that you rubbed one
out to your wife's sister, Huh?
What if that ever got, I wonder if
there was fucking video of that.
You fucking fucking rub one out to your
wife's fucking sister and we could see
the fucking video that's playing
in your God damn head. Really?
You're going to judge this
guy cause he's into feet.
I don't judge him for that Shit.
I do judge them for being a shit talking
jackass who sounds like one of my moron
buddies at a fucking sports bar.
I will trash him for that.
So with that, who do you guys think is
going to win the Superbowl? Because I,
for one have no fucking idea.
I have no faith in my team.
I don't even know who they already
more, they'll let my, my patriots,
they like a drug addict,
you know,
are they clean? Are they cleaned
this week? And they're going to play,
they're gonna play fucking defense.
Are they just gonna? Uh, I dunno.
I Dunno.
And I don't like that,
that we basically showed a loss
to the fucking packers. Uh,
but Aaron Rodgers was out and even then,
we still should have fucking loss,
but they didn't manage the
clock. Right. And, uh, you know,
we lost to the jets once jets
could come in and beat us,
they could still come in and beat
us in our own fucking place. I mean,
that's still kind of way
football is right now. So,
which is why I don't understand the whole
rex Ryan shit-talking that's what it
was about. So there you go. Let's see.
Let's move on to something else here.
Let's go with advice. Uh, Bill. Hey,
I just want to write you and say
I got let it go for Christmas.
Um, I really needed it to, my
girlfriend dumped me on Christmas Eve.
Uh, so you know, my Christmas suck,
but your DVD really helped
me out a lot last night.
I know what you say about breakups.
Six weeks of pain and then it gets easier.
I said we were together for nine months
and out of the blue on Christmas Eve,
she called me up and said she needed
time for herself and her daughter.
That makes it tough too. I got really
close to her kid. Here's my question.
What's the worst breakup you've ever had?
And have you ever,
have you ever been dumped
over the holidays? All right,
there's a number of things going
on here, sir. First of all, uh,
that's a real honest move on her part.
You know,
that whole fucking thing where you just
go through a Christmas cause you don't
want to hurt somebody's
feelings. You know, it's,
there's no good time for a break.
And she just could not go through the
phoniness of celebrating Christmas with
you when she knew she was
going to fucking drop.
The other shoe of that
fucking expression goes.
So I gotta give her props for being
fucking honest. But uh, and then also,
do you know, you can do
better than hooking up with
some chick already has a kid.
And I hate to be mean.
I'm not trying to trash women out there
who have fucking kids in this single,
in that type of shit. But I'm trying
to give this guy something positive.
All right? You know, it's like, yeah,
you got it. You got it down to
six weeks, it's going to suck.
This is what you want to do.
Just go to the gym,
go to the fucking shit.
This is what women do.
Women fucking cry it
out with their friends.
They get out of this system and then
they go to the fucking gym and the next
time you run into them,
they want you to have that moment.
Why the fuck did I dump? You went,
guys, we never do that. What do we do?
We get fucking drunk.
Get a big fat fucking John Travolta head
and then go out and try to bang some
skank at three in the morning. Don't
do that to yourself. All right?
Just know it's going to hurt and fucking,
you know,
go for spoon with your pillow and cry
it out and then go to the fucking gym.
Put on some music that's gonna motivate
you. Go see that movie the fighter.
All right, go get fucking motivated.
We'll do that shit. And then, uh,
then just go out and just start hitting
on chicks at a completely way out of
your fucking leak. And, uh, you
know, just go talk some shit.
And then he got the out.
I'm not ready to be in a relationship.
I got broken up with on
Christmas fucking eve.
I'm not even trying to talk to women.
You do that.
You fucking do the reverse
sell you backing up,
they're walking towards your Dick.
That's how you do it. You know,
you'll get a sympathy, blowjob or
some just open your fucking mouth.
Don't be negative. Keep them fucking
laugh and spent a couple of plates.
Something will happen for you. Next
thing you know, he'd be like, Wow dad,
that I almost get involved with the fuck.
I almost was thinking about
getting married to some
woman already had a fucking
kid, you know, who's never really
gonna consider you her dad.
It's going to have a bunch of issues
and a dad's not going to be around when,
when her daughter goes
through her her slot years,
cause she's trying to find
another father figure.
You don't want to be around for that shit.
You did. All right. So anyways, he said,
here's my question.
What's the worst breakup you've ever had
and have you ever been dumped over the
holidays? Uh, worst
breakup I ever had was I
broke up with this girl who
then ended up stalking me.
She told me she was pregnant.
Uh,
I believed her.
I got back into her life.
And then obviously I've realized,
you know,
when she was never showing
that she wasn't pregnant. Yeah.
I had one of those,
just a complete fucking psycho with
stock me at my day job and all that.
She was a fucking nightmare.
Um,
had one those and have ever been dumped
over the holidays. No, I haven't.
I've mainly been the person,
uh,
that's dumped people. But I did get
dumped, uh, the fuck did I get dumped?
It was in September.
Yeah. It was September.
September. Yeah. Yeah.
And it was, it sucked. It was fucking
brutal. And I did the dumb shit.
I went out and I drank and
um, I didn't that, that's,
you know, something that's the basis of
my advice that I give you guys when you,
men are women when you go
through a breakup, is just
allow yourself to know that it's gonna
suck. Yes. It's going to suck. Yes.
You're gonna come home.
The phone isn't going to ring and you're
going to be sitting there trying to put
the pieces back together going,
what the fuck did I used to do
with all this extra time and
just go through that is the best thing
that I can tell you in fucking embrace it
and just know it's going to hurt.
And uh,
that's the best advice I can give
you because I did not do that.
The worst thing you want to do was go out,
start booze and shot a bank,
somebody else, and then go into
a fucking rebound relationship.
I did that a couple of times.
It's fucking brutal.
It's not what the fuck you want to do.
So, uh, I know we had a cup of questions.
Somebody I keep getting questions about
on the opiate Anthony show a Patrice
O'Neal and a Kevin Hart talked about
this detrashing that I took and uh,
it was a long fucking time ago. I
haven't listened to the audio yet. Uh,
just look it up on Youtube.
I'm sure they have the audio up,
uh,
without even listening to the audio.
Whatever they said is more than truth.
It was an epic 50 fucking
minute trashing that I took.
Um, what the fuck was his
story? St at the comedy cellar.
All right,
how do I go to,
where do we start to see the Yankees
were playing the Braves in the fucking
world series and I guess it was deuce.
These groups of people from Atlanta
wanted to, uh, we're going to take,
that's right.
They were taking two buses
to Yankee stadium to go to
the game and they wanted a
comedian to perform on the
bus on the way to the stadium.
All right. Which obviously is
the most nightmare gig ever.
They were going to pay you like 500
bucks and give you a world series ticket.
All right?
So that the Gig was offered
to meet like SD was like,
who's the two biggest sports fans I know
we don't hear. And so she offered an,
and actually don't have enough money in
the bank will actually consider doing
this. So she approached me
and Jim Norton about the Gig.
So me and Norton are just
talking about it going through,
this is going to be the
worst fucking Gig ever.
But you get to go to the world series
and we were both thinking about it.
So the next day over 24 hours Norton and
just goes, fuck that. I'm not doing it.
So I was going to do
it. I was like, fucking,
I mean it's not gonna be that bad a gig.
That's the thing about it.
It wouldn't have been that bad a gig.
I basically was going to get paid to go
to a world series game and to get paid
to do what the fuck I
was going to do anyways,
which is trashed the Yankees all
the way up to Yankee stadium.
That's the only part about the story.
That's bullshit is them talking about
what a horrific gig it would have been.
It would have been a fucking cake walk
compared to those college gigs I did
where they didn't have a
fucking microphone and they
stand you in a hallway.
It would be a bunch of drunk fans,
excited to see their team that
didn't have a shot in fucking hell.
A beating the Yankees and all I was
going to do was tell him what a fag Jeter
was for fucking 30 minutes,
a half hour fucking set
would have been a joke.
All I would have to do is trashed
the Yankees the whole fuck away up.
I get 500 bucks and I get a world
series ticket and the second I get off,
I can screw.
I can leave those guys and they get to
go to a world series game and fucking
Yankee Stadium. So I'm like, I'm
going to fucking do it. Right.
So I didn't know that Jim had said
that he wasn't going to do it.
So we're sitting down there at the table
down at the cellar and it's starting up.
Everybody's giving each other shit. So I
start giving Norton Shit about whatever,
about as chinless face, uh,
his little ears or whatever,
fucking awful hooded
sweatshirt that he was wearing.
And then I got him with a couple of jabs
and he felt the overhand right come in
and he needed to stop it. And
he just goes, whatever, bus boy.
And it was like ef Hutton.
Everybody fucking stopped and went,
what,
why did you just call them busboy?
And I immediately was like,
he's going do it too.
And Somehow Jim got out of it and just,
he literally threw me under the bus and
then they found out I was doing the Gig.
And it just so happened that
night that all the fucking,
the big boys where there was
Patrice Norton was there,
Kevin Hart, Rich Vos, Keith Robinson,
right fucking there, the Tyson
Holyfield, George Foreman,
all of that. And I'm standing
there like fucking a tex Cobb.
And I took a 50 minute, I took
a headlining set, killing,
standing ovation set of
shit for doing that Gig.
And I was still going to do it.
I was still going to do it
even after the fucking trash.
And cause I'm thinking I'm going
to the fucking world series.
I don't give a shit,
you know.
And Patrice was trashing me and I
didn't give a fuck what he said.
His advice I never would've listened to
because Patrice was one of the biggest
pussies when it came to
performing hell gigs.
Like when we used to do colleges,
uh,
this guy used to book us on
colleges and it would be me,
him and Robert Kelly or meet
him in Norton or whatever.
And this dude never wanted to go on first
cause first sucks because you've got a
warm up the crowd and he never wanted
to go on last because you had to follow
the other two acts.
He
always wanted to go on second and he a
and then he'd go on second and he would
go over his fucking time like
the selfish country is. And uh,
so I was just thinking, Hey, you
know this guy, this guy fucking a,
this guy retires from comedy every two
weeks when he sees a hack kill on stage.
I don't give a fuck what he thinks.
But it was,
it wasn't until the end when he actually
looked at me when the trashing was over
and he said, Bill, he goes, I
will stand in front of that bus.
Don't do that Gig. I'll buy you a ticket
to the world series. Don't do that.
And then I was sitting there going
like, wow, this is actually like,
he's not even joking right now. He's
trying to tell me for the love of God,
have a little bit of self fucking worth.
And he shit.
That was the thing.
After a 50 minute trashin isn't
as embarrassing as that was,
nothing was worse than the shame of him
telling me that I could actually afford
a world series ticket. At that point,
I wasn't really even thinking that.
So I decided in that moment
I decided not to do the Gig,
which I don't think came out
on the opiate Anthony show.
They think I did the Gig.
I never did the Gig.
And I actually passed it off to another
comedian who was further down the ladder
than I was. And uh, he didn't even ask me,
but I always made a promise that I
would never say who did the Gig. And uh,
I don't know.
Next time I go on opion Anthony,
I'll talk to the dude who actually did
the Gig and see if he wants to call in
and talk about the Gig. But that's the
only, I haven't listened to the audio yet,
but whatever jokes that they said,
there was some classic ones.
I remember Portree say, well,
hey bill, when they bring you up,
are you going to come out of the bathroom?
Are you going to walk up
up those little stairs?
That and then also me finishing
my set. Go and hey, thanks a lot.
And then I sit down in the bus seat and
then look over my shoulder and shake
everybody's hands as they go to get off
the bus. Was I going to fucking hold the,
uh, you know, the bus intercom thing,
what I do it over that Yada, Yada,
all that and fit and this will kill me.
They had jokes for 50 fucking minutes.
All that was true,
but I never did the Gig.
I never did the GIC and a,
and I still maintain,
it wouldn't have been that bad of
a fucking Gig. It wouldn't have.
But what have been a joke,
bill?
Get on a bus for a half an
hour and trash the Yankees.
Do you think he can do that? We'll give
you 500 bucks in a world series ticket.
Absolutely. I would have been
drinking with them at anytime.
I ran out of shit to talk about the
Yankees. He just look out the bus,
hey look at the tits on that fucking
whore and they'd all go nuts.
All I had to do is support
the south in the civil war.
There was so many different ways that
I could then what it would have been a
fucking cakewalk of fucking cake walk.
And I didn't end up doing it.
I didn't end up doing it,
which actually was better because the
first time I went to a world series ended
up being a,
I went to game two with a 2004,
that boring ass world series. But it
was exciting cause we finally won it.
So they, he goes to that.
That is the story. Yes. They
trashed the shit out of me,
but I never did the Gig.
I was shamed out of doing it and I gave
it to another comedian who will remain
nameless. Actually, you
know what, here, let me,
let me do a little cross promotion here.
Uh,
I will reveal the name the next
time I do the opie and Anthony Show.
If they still give a fuck,
if they still give a shit,
if the story has legs as they say in
the business. So a, so there you go.
There's that fucking story.
All right.
And I'll try to remember the name of
this podcast in case it gets so many,
a couple of more questions about it and
I'll just say refer to the podcast on
December 27th. Um, all right
you two videos of the week.
Um, these are all going to be
on the [inaudible] podcast.com.
You can watch all of these uh,
the so called white man.
Somebody sent a great
video of somebody they do,
didn't have a microphone but he was,
he was talking about all
how the white man, you know,
is fucking with everybody the way he
twisted up religion and all that shit,
which is totally true. But in the end he
goes, cause God is actually a black man.
So basically it's like everything
that white people just did.
I am now going to do from my perspective,
which is the one thing that I've learned
when I being on the road that everybody
is the same and it includes the bad shit.
You know that liberal thought that
you know everybody is the thing,
but it's only good shit. Everybody
has the ability to be a scientist,
to be a doctor. You know a fucking
teacher. Everybody has. Yes,
yes they do and they also have the ability
to be a fucking CEO at Enron to be a
rapist and to be a fucking serial
killer and all the bad shit.
Everything to be a war criminal, a
fucking dictator, everybody that is not,
that is not an exclusively white thing
because white people get blamed for evil.
Like we're the only evil ones
in the planet. We are not.
We are just the best at it. We are the
Michael Jordans of evil. Everybody.
I challenge your race to top my race
with the evilness, but you got it in you.
You got to know that. All right.
You got to know that you have in,
in you the same way you have it in you
to be a doctor or a lawyer or a teacher.
You also have it in you to be a,
a,
a complete fucking sociopath.
Uh, so there's, there's,
there's my fucking 2 cents.
All right. Clumsy report
or knocks down. Uh,
I don't even know how to say Jenga Tower
and he wanted this leaning tower of
Pisa.
Uh,
Fva tow rope fail.
This is somebody towing their friend's
car down the street with a rope and it
doesn't go that well.
Merry Christmas bitch.
Need I say more Harvard sailing team.
Boys will be girls and on from
funny or die drunk history.
And I think it,
I think that's it for the podcast.
This has been a very long one.
I Gift Card really quick.
Let me read this gift card, Dude. What
is your deal with gift certificates?
This guy right here is the exact reason
why I don't like gift certificates.
Would you rather get some shitty
sweater or boxer beast from your aunt or
brother in law or a gift certificate from
Amazon or best buy where you could buy
something. You actually
like, Hey, fuck head.
Why don't you not go out and buy
a shitty sweater? A boxer briefs.
See you on creative content.
Maybe you should give out a gift card.
That's why I don't like
it because you know,
it's like you're out there and you buy
somebody a great fucking gift and then
they go, hey, you go shop for yourself.
Fuck face. It's lazy. That's why.
That's why I don't fucking like
it. I don't mind it. If I get,
if we both agree to get each
other gifts certificates,
I don't mind that when I'm out there
actually trying to buy you a fucking
coolest gift and you come up with that,
you just write me a check.
You know like I'm some drunk whore going
to say you fucking son raped somebody
and you're running for Senate and
you need the problem to go away.
That's why I don't like it. So go
fuck yourself. I'm all right. Revenge.
I got to read this quickly here. Um, which
is gonna cause all kinds of problems.
Uh, all right. I went to a local
junior college, oh wait a second,
I jumped in too far. Uh, this may be more
of a story of lashing out than revenge.
I actually think this is a story of
revenge and I like the story cause this is
eyeball to eyeball even though it
was a little off Samuelson here. Uh,
my senior year I dated a
beautiful underclassmen.
She was my first love and firstly
we dated through the summer.
After graduation I went on to
a local junior college. Um,
the next year, Jesus Christ shop
class guy right here. All right. Uh,
we were still dating when
school started up the next year.
I had a lot of friends that were still
in high school and one of my friend's
friends told me that he started seeing
my girlfriend hanging out at school with
another good friend of mine.
Uh,
my girlfriend was acting shady,
so I knew something was up. Um,
for years during the football season,
a big group of guys would get together
on Sundays and play a game of tackle
football.
Uh,
this guy who was seen with my girlfriend
was among the guys that showed up to
play with me though to play with
the, uh, everybody. Me and this guy,
this other guy, you name it all names.
I'm trying to skip over the names here.
Me and this other guy
would normally play Qb,
so we would be the two to
pick teams each week. Um,
the quarterback on the other team
was also a good friend of mine.
The friend of mine,
all these fucking names here,
the friend of mine who was messing
with my girl didn't know that.
I was aware that he and my girl had been
flirting at school. So I asked my buddy,
the QB on the other team to pick this
Douche who's messing with my girl.
And at some point during the game,
send them in on a hard five.
And in I, I don't know what
that, is that like a postpaid,
I guess that's a crossing
pattern and lead them high.
He's basically going over the middle.
He's gonna throw them,
throw the ball high and
just out of his reach,
leaving this guy completely exposed.
So anyways,
he goes a few plays into the game.
They come out of the huddle and my buddy,
the QB on the other team gives me a look.
He goes,
I called a two one two defense.
Jesus Christ,
the most professional
pickup football game ever.
So I bring in the nickel defense.
I had to call a timeout because
we had too many men on the field.
I call it a two one two defense
and took the short ride zone.
The ball was snapped and this douche
bag who's flirting with my girl came off
the line, took a hard left and
in slow motion, ran into my zone.
I delay one or two seconds and
begin the path to the collision.
My buddy let him perfect.
So he had to pick up a little speed to
get to the ball and he extended both arms
to the sky.
And of course he's looking back at
the quarterback to Jesus Christ.
The second the ball hit his hands.
I bury my shoulder into his stomach.
I grabbed the back of his knees and I
pull up and drive them into the ground.
Now I can't define the word squelched,
but he definitely let out a sound that
old that I can only describe as squelched.
Uh, yeah, it really that,
that word makes it sound like you
actually hit a really ripe melon.
The entire field erupted with a holy shit.
My little league coach would have given
me two stars on my helmet for this
fucking hit.
I felt good about it for about three
seconds and the than the remorse,
and I feel bad to this day for
setting this guy up the way I did.
It took a few minutes for him
to get up. Uh, but he was fine.
I don't know about Karma,
but a few weeks later, uh,
this dude that he drilled into the ground
was banging his ex girlfriend and I
met my rebound that I dated
for the next five years.
She turned out to be the devil or herself.
I might not believe in God,
but I've hooked up.
I've looked the devil in her evil eye
as I shot a load into her evil cunt.
Jesus Christ. Um, I don't think
Karma got you. I think, uh,
he was going banger no matter what. And
I think he got a nice shot in there. Um,
it was a little cheesy that you had
your friends set them up, but uh,
but fuck him. That's what
he gets. That's your girl.
He shouldn't have been doing that.
He was wrong. You were right. And uh,
as far as Karma goes,
I view Karma is like,
uh, what's that shit where you look at
the stars to see if you're going to get a
chicken sandwich that day. What
do you call it? Is it astrology?
Astronomy is the study of
stars. Astrology. Yeah.
Like I don't believe in astrology.
You know, and anybody who does,
you go, okay, you believe in it. I,
you just go, what's your sign? And I,
and they tell you this sign and
then read somebody else's horoscope.
If they're a gem and I read
a Taurus and the garden,
how does that pertain to your
life? The, okay. It means
this, this, and this. And Go. Yeah,
see that was Taurus. So there you go.
You can fucking, this is so vague.
You can attribute it to anything.
Something wonderful is going to
happen today. Just be careful.
You don't close it off or it won't happen.
So then if something wonderful doesn't
happen, yeah, then walk while I,
I must've been closed off.
I need to be more open and then
they get off Scott free. Right?
I feel the same way about Karma.
Karma is something that if you,
there's ups and downs in
life, okay? And if you just,
you're waiting for
something bad to happen,
something bad is going to fucking happen.
No matter how good you are,
something bad's going to fucking happen.
You know, buy brand new pair of sneakers,
someone's going to step on him. You know,
you're like, why I starve a fucking,
I starve. I sponsor a starving child.
I don't fuck around. I'm a good guy.
Why did somebody step on my sneaker?
Because the world is full of content.
It's impossible not to run into him.
You know,
I think Karma exists if you believe in it.
I think if you don't believe in Karma,
like you never really, you don't
really have any bad shit happen to you.
There you go.
That's what I think about Karma.
I am an hour and 17 fucking minutes
into this podcast. Ladies and gentlemen,
I think it's time to watch to end the
podcast here. I hope you enjoyed it.
Hope you guys all had a very
merry Christmas, a happy
Kwanzaa, happy Hanukkah,
or maybe it just said fuck it all.
And I'm going to take a few days off and,
uh, that is it. That's the
podcast. Please, please.
Oh, please. Well, the shows,
they're all sold out. So go scalp a
ticket. I, speaking of Jim Norton,
the man who threw me under the bus,
and it took them 10
years to make up for it,
actually made up for it when you put me
on down and dirty and he hooked me up
with opiate Anthony. Uh, but let's
say I don't count those, you know,
cause I'm into astrology. He hooked
me up again with this awesome Gig, uh,
that he does every year
at the, uh, uh, fuck.
I'm gonna screw this up down in Atlantic
city. And this year he was like,
you know what,
why should I take it all for myself?
Why don't I share it with some
friends and I'm doing a show at the,
the fucking casino down
there and the Atlantic city.
Why don't I know the name of it? Fucking
internet doesn't work on my bedroom.
Whatever. It's fucking sold out
anyways, but it's me, Jim Norton,
Jim Breuer and David Tell it's going to
be a fucking unbelievable night at three
shows. If you can't make that,
if you didn't get tickets,
it's cause it's already sold out.
Um,
my next Gig is I'm going to be in Dallas,
Texas on the final weekend in January,
the week of the NFL pro bowl,
the 27th,
28th, 29th, I believe. That weekend I'm
going to be at the Improv in Dallas.
I'm sorry, 28, 29 and 30
Improv in Dallas, Texas.
Please come out. I got a brand
new killer hour, uh, stuff. Uh,
anything else?
Oh,
red sox fans are baseball fans and
generally should check this out. Uh,
Steve Gorman from the, uh, black
Crowes has its own podcast. Of course,
I don't have the fucking
link because I'm an idiot.
Steve Gorman sports sgs is
the name of the podcast.
Great podcast.
He interviews Kevin Useless and uh,
[inaudible] he just,
he's got a great interview style where
he just gets the other person to relax
and he starts talking about
just all kinds of cool shit.
Favorite ballparks,
favorite restaurants.
If you're into sports performance
enhancing drugs, Pete rose,
should he be in the hall of fame
or not having entourages uh,
team chemistry, all the shit you
want to tell. And it's great.
It goes on for well over an hour and
it's totally fucking entertaining.
Highly recommend that podcast keeps
getting better every time I hear it.
And that's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
I'm going to be interview
with Nick Swardson, uh,
this week for a very special podcast
and I am also going to the rose bowl,
the granddaddy of a mall
on a New Year's Day.
And I am going to be stone
fucking sober this year.
I know you guys are all born right now
cause you want to hear the happy drunk
stories where I'm sick of
being a drunk on that day.
I would like to remember like I,
I went to a game and Sanchez
played the USC Penn State.
I went to that game and I had
never even heard of Sanchez.
That's how drunk I was.
So the thing that I could have been alive,
booing that guy, I would've
made a different seat. They
still fucking killed the,
uh, they still kill Penn
state. All right? Whatever.
That's the podcast to this week. God
bless all the, uh, have a great week.
Don't take anything
shed.
And I go fuck yourself.
[inaudible] so
[inaudible] [inaudible].